i'm jake johnson and i'm shameik Moore
and this is your weekend ticket both new
in theaters this weekend mortal engines
the mule and spider-man into the spider
verse what will you see this is your
weekend ticket mortal engines comes out
this weekend this post-apocalyptic
adventure film based on the novel of the
same name is set in the world where
cities are on massive traction driven
contraptions and Tom who's never set
foot on real ground now finds himself
thrown off the city car with an assassin
the screenplay was written by Fran Walsh
Philippa boyens and the Lord of the
Rings director Peter Jackson this movie
is for you if you like post-apocalyptic
books turn movies Peter Jackson's style
adventure gets you all revved up or
you've ever lived in a city that's on
top of a big attraction card thing also
at this weekend the mule a reality stunt
movie starring Johnny Knoxville the
meals at crime drama starring and
produced and directed by Clint Eastwood
this based on a true story story follows
a World War two veteran who became a
drug dealer and courier for the Sinaloa
cartel this film also features Bradley
Cooper Laurence Fishburne Michael Pena
Dianne Wiest and Andy Garcia this movies
for you if you like east woody and
dramas like gran torino or trouble with
the curb drug trafficking crime dramas
are your thing or you feel inspired by
seniors who are still active in the work
force
finally spider-man into the spider verse
comes out this weekend this animated
spider-man film starring Jake Johnson
and shameik Moore involves a parallel
dimension and multiple spider-man
team-up in an effort to save all of
reality it's like a superhero universe
mashup but all the superheroes are the
same superhero just different do animals
talk in this dimension cuz I don't want
to freak him out this movie is for you
if you like anything spider-man you want
to see a real cool fresh take on the
spider-man story or if you've ever
wondered what it would you like to meet
a different dimension version of
yourself that is your weekend tickets
what will you see check back next week
for how to spend your time over the
holidays
[Music]
you